okay so this is the space I want to turn
into my office it's extremely small it's
literally just this wall right here this
is a um like Supply Closet where I keep
my cleaning items and I'm going to show
you a quick layout of my apartment so
you so you can see the predicament I'm
in I just don't know where to put my
desk until last night I was like man I'm
building apps all the time I'm editing
videos all the time I need an actual
place to like sit usually I sit at my
Island where like those two chairs are
but it's like no I I want a monitor I
want you know multiple screens and
everything so I took a walk around my
apartment and it was like you know what
this wall isn't doing anything it's not
doing anything for anybody so let
me let me do something here okay I
ordered some tools because from from the
videos I watched to get the desk the
desk to get the door off of its hinges I
need a hammer and either a nail or a
screwdriver and I don't have that cuz
after
all I'm only just a girl don't
forget I'm also just a girl
oh wait oh thank God I was like shoot I
don't want to open all these boxes to
find
the tool set so I just picked one and
prayed for the
best look at God it's all pink and cute
so you know I like
it oh
oh
I did
it oh that's so cool I'm not a handy
person at
all let me give you a quick peek
here this is not like the biggest closet
but I think it'll be cute when I take it
all out and make it into like that
office type closet okay cool cool cool
cool let me take out all this cleaning
stuff
[Music]
and
it
open
[Music]
please okay all it's open okay I pray to
God this isn't a to set up because
the picture makes it seem like a very
simple desk here's a picture of it like
a
super simple looking desk with just some
shelves and whatnot where's the
manual ah let's put the manual at the
very bottom of this box hell
yeah
okay there's a slight chance I'm going
need to go to Home Depot to get that
power
[Music]
drill
I just want to get to decorating so
quickly what time is
it so like the next thing is literally
to just anchor to the
wall but I have instructions for drywall
application in non-
drywall what does that mean to me um not
much
because like where well I I I don't I
don't know what that means what what are
the options drywall or
like
cement oh my God oh God okay let me call
my dad hold
on hello yo how are you are you doing
good I'm trying to mount um something
onto my
wall well is the next day and it's it's
up it's up by the grace of God it is up
now I can actually get to the fun part
and I'm really excited for it I to
actually open up these boxes behind me
and start decorating it this is now a
desk haul so yeah let me show youall I
literally
literally got kind of like
everything you could get for a desk from
the monitor down
to the lamp and
Decor I
wanted especially since it has this desk
has that ladder style I was like let me
put some hanging plants at like the top
shelf so it can droop down okay then I
have
this lamp it's a cute
little mushroom
and it comes with remotes cuz it has
different light settings so I was like
hell yeah for like mood setting and
everything oh that's so cool it feels
like a mushroom too I I didn't think it
would I thought it was going to be like
hard I didn't think it would feel like a
mushroom like all
plush oh it's my digital clock oh that's
so cool it's all it's like very
reflective I got some storage bins
because
now I have an exposed closet I was like
let me get some storage bins where I can
put in things like camera equipment
gear things like that without it looking
now hectic okay
awesome I think this is my
laptop pad or like desk pad yes it
is oh that's perfect okay so this is the
first thing I'll put down after I clean
the desk
is the Whiteboard
so when I'm
coating I love having a whiteboard to
write out my
MVP my just next steps and things like
that it just like I don't know it helps
me problem solve especially if I'm
debugging and
so that's a cute little
whiteboard and here's my keyboard oh my
goodness I'm so excited I've never
gotten like a cute keyboard I always
just use the default keyboard on my
laptop okay and finally is my monitor y
I'm looking at this now I hope this
isn't too big for the desk oh no oh no
Well it can't
possibly it can't possibly be this big
though I'm thinking like
this hopefully okay ready set
go oh there's this cardboard in
here I was like excited for like
a okay now let's move the cardboard and
hopefully it's that hopefully it's that
ha
moment
[Music]
I'm pretty notorious for not measuring
things and this is what happens when we
don't not even not measuring things not
checking the dimensions of things I
order but it's okay nothing little
scissors can't
fix oh
no does this not fit you know what it's
okay let me just take off this Shelf
[Music]
okay now that I'm setting up I realized
there a couple things I'm missing and I
just looked at my um account my Amazon
account and it looks like this one
package was dropped off in our mail room
which is extremely not secure um and
I've gotten like tens of things stolen
like hundreds of dollars things stolen
by the grace of
God my package was still
[Music]
there